acteur actrice il ya mille parcours il
ya mille personnes qui s'est tellement
personnel ça touche à notre corse à tous
sur notre intimité il n'y a pas un
acteur une actrice qui vous racontera la
même chose sur la manière dont il est
arrivé là comment il a vécu quel a été
son évolution grâce au x avec le x ou
sans le x clairement c'est beaucoup trop
personnelle pour notre corps est un
outil de travail mais c'est avant tout
notre corps
pour ce qui est de la souffrance moi
personnellement encore une fois
probablement que je suis privilégié trop
sérieuse
je ne sais pas je ma seule souffrance
depuis toutes ces années c'est le
jugement social c'est le manque de
reconnaissance c'est de devoir me
défendre constamment d'être éduqué
d'avoir fait des études
d'être capable de tenir une conversation
d'être capable d'aimer et d'être aimés
d'être une belle fille d'être une amie
fidèle d'être témoin de mariage d'être
marraine d'un bébé tout ça est impacté
de parler l'image qu'on se fait des
actrices x et ça vient du fait même que
à l'origine on est on est on est bannie
on est stigmatisée on n'est pas reconnue
comme étant une profession on ne nous
permet pas de pouvoir dire simplement à
l'apéro et toi tu fais quoi dans la vie
h actrice porno c'est pas possible en
fait malheureusement ce n'est pas
possible et puis comme j'aime les choses
faciles j'ai choisi un métier à côté qui
les valorisait que depuis la crise du
coc vide
voilà un petit côté un petit côté maso
probablement mai et si aujourd'hui j'ai
été autant préparer c'est parce que j'ai
déjà j'estime que c'est respectueux
envers vous êtes en infirmière j'ai fait
une soutenance de mémoire quand même je
sais me présenter devant des gens mais
surtout l'opportunité qui nous est
donnée est unique nous ne sommes pas
consultés habituellement à les
associations féministes le sont beaucoup
l ont elles c'est une grosse machine
capable de beaucoup de choses nous ne
sommes pas une grosse machine capable de
beaucoup de choses
malheureusement on est toutes
indépendantes en a pas de syndicat on
n'est pas une grosse une grosse
entreprise nous ne sommes que des
actrices des actes d ex actrice
[Musique]